depuis presque une semaine le
thermomètre va et vient autour des 30
degrés il a même taquiné les 33 degrés
sous-abris du côté de Cambrai et un de
nos soucis numéro 1 maintenant c'est
mais qu'est-ce qu'on peut bien faire
pour se rafraîchir les gens en soif avec
le beau temps on vend des diabolo morts
des diaboloss au citron mais enfin quand
même il faut dire une chose c'est que la
bière est en la boisson préférée de la
région
on en boit quand même habituellement on
emploi une on en boit deux bah
maintenant on en boit trois on en boit
quatre quoi qu'il soit 11h qu'il soit
midi qui soit 6h du moment qu'on a chaud
on a soif on boit de la bière les gens
du Nord ne manqueront pas de leur
breuvage préféré et puis la bière ce
n'est pas mauvais pour la santé à
condition d'être raisonnable bien sûr le
Comité national de défense contre
l'alcoolisme dit même qu'on peut en
boire jusqu'à 1 litre et demi sans
danger pour la santé dit que la bière
fait transpirer mais enfin on en voit
quand même
allez alors